une pluie de débris qui s'abat sur la
banlieue de denver
un réacteur droit qui prend feu et une
frayeur immense pour les 231 passagers
du boeing 777
après une panne spectaculaire samedi
dernier place désormais à l'inspection
des moteurs concernés
l'administration fédérale américaine de
l'aviation at en effet décidé de faire
subir un examen approfondi des pales des
moteurs de ses boeing avant qu'ils
puissent voler de nouveau
nous voulons comprendre ce qui s'est
passé et prendre les mesures nécessaires
afin d'éviter qu'un événement similaires
se reproduisent à l'avenir la fédération
américaine de l'aviation a examiné
toutes les données de sécurité
disponibles après l'incident selon les
premières conclusions de l'enquêté les
dommages constatés sur place sont
compatibles avec une fatigue du métal
des pales de la soufflante du moteur à
la suite de l'incident de samedi dernier
qui n'a fait aucun blessé 128 appareils
dont 60,9 en service ont été immobilisés
par boeing un incident qui pourrait
affecter le marché mondial de l'aviation
le royaume-uni at-on effet décidé
d'interdire son espace aérien au boeing
777 concernés pour cause boeing en est
pas à son premier accroc à partir de
2019 son fleuron le 737 max est cloué au
sol pendant près de deux ans après deux
accidents ayant fait 346 morts si
l'incident de samedi dernier l'a fait
aucun blessé
il représente un nouveau revers pour
boeing dont le titre a perdu plus de 2%
lundi en bourse